[Música]
y
ucrania es a menudo llamada el granero
europa pero la guerra ha provocado
importantes interrupciones en la
producción y las exportaciones agrícolas
del país en las últimas semanas vídeos
aficionados han documentado ataques a
las granjas e instalaciones de
almacenamiento de alimentos de ucrania
lo que hace pensar que rusia está
atacando la infraestructura agrícola del
país que tim huevos experta en seguridad
alimentaria del centro de estudios
estratégicos e internacionales nos habla
del tema
lo que vemos son ataques directos a los
medios de productividad agrícola en
ucrania en todos los aspectos en los
campos donde vemos que rusia coloca
minas a los cobertizos de ganado lechero
donde atacan para matar al ganado a los
silos donde se almacenan los cereales
pero también las vías férreas donde se
transportan los cereales desde las
granjas a los mercados en todos los
aspectos nada se ha salvado de esta
guerra
sabemos que rusia está atacando
deliberadamente al sector agrícola
ucraniano
el kremlin por supuesto lo niega pero
eso es precisamente lo que están
haciendo y hemos obtenido imágenes de
depósitos que se utilizan para almacenar
alimentos para almacenar cereales
los agricultores traían sus productos
para almacenarlos aquí y luego los
camiones venían a recoger este producto
para exportarlo este es un ejemplo en el
que vimos la destrucción completa de
partes de este depósito hay casas
alrededor de este que quedaron
prácticamente intactas lo que nos indica
que rusia está atacando directamente
estos lugares y lanzando un ataque
deliberado para perjudicar al sector
agrícola ucraniano hay varios cobertizos
lecheros unos 10 creo y varios han sido
atacados directamente y destruidos por
completo otros han sufrido daños menores
que podrían reducir la cantidad de
producción de las instalaciones de las
tropas rusas también han sido acusadas
de robar seriales y suministros
agrícolas en las ciudades ucranianas
este vídeo por ejemplo muestra un convoy
de vehículos rusos que transportan
tractores de un concesionario en la
ciudad ucraniana ocupada de melitópol
algunos de estos costosos vehículos
contaban con dispositivos gps que
permitieron rastrear los en chechenia
unos días después el alcalde de
melitópol dijo que las tropas rusas
habían vaciado los depósitos de cereales
de la ciudad estos accidentes podrían
tener graves consecuencias para la
economía y la seguridad alimentaria de
ucrania la agricultura es sumamente
importante para la economía ucraniana
aporta alrededor del 10 por ciento del
pib anual de ucr al cuanto mayor sea el
grado de destrucción causado por rusia
menos ingresos recibirá el gobierno
ucraniano de la agricultura así que creo
que este es un aspecto importante del
impacto en la economía ucrania aunque la
guerra se terminada mañana se
necesitaría mucho tiempo y muchos
recursos para que el sector agrícola
ucraniano pueda estar como antes de la
guerra
[Música]
desde el 8 de mayo las manifestaciones
han ido en aumento en irán especialmente
en el sur del país comenzaron después de
que las autoridades decidirán dejar de
subvencionar varios alimentos básicos el
precio de los huevos el aceite de cocina
y la leche se dispararon hasta un 300
por ciento este movimiento es el más
grande desde la revuelta de 2019 contra
el aumento de los precios de la gasolina
durante la cual al menos 1500 personas
fueron asesinadas por las fuerzas del
orden las manifestaciones en las que se
escuchaban arengas contra el líder
supremo alí jamenéi fueron reprimidas
rápidamente el 16 de mayo los activistas
iraníes contaron al menos cinco muertes
nosotros hablamos con un joven de
juzestán una de las regiones con más
manifestaciones ella pidió mantener el
anonimato por su seguridad por lo que
transcribimos sus palabras
el internet está cortado pero la ciudad
no es grande así que la gente pudo
reunirse espontáneamente en la calle
principal
[Aplausos]
y con mis hermanos y primos creo que
éramos varios miles de personas ancianos
jóvenes hombres y muchas mujeres
cantamos consignas contra el régimen los
mulás deben irse
esta mañana
todas estas proclamas contra jamenéi se
deben a que él es el responsable de la
situación sus políticas desde hace 30
años nos han llevado a este punto
y seguiremos hasta el final
intentaron dispersar nos dispararon
gases lacrimógenos dispararon al aire
escuché que hubo heridos en nuestra
ciudad hay muchas fuerzas policiales y
basit
mirando a ti
ya nadie para gilbert
por chávez
pero
mi hermano mis primos y yo somos
titulados universitarios y todos estamos
desempleados tenemos que vivir con
nuestros padres que no pueden llegar a
fin de mes
hace tres meses que no podemos comprar
carne y ahora los precios de los
alimentos básicos están por las nubes
pan pasta huevos que otra cosa podemos
hacer si hay pan cuesta el doble que
antes
ya es suficiente espero que la gente de
otras ciudades se unan a nosotros como
en 2019 para hacer una nueva revuelta
general pero esta vez tenemos que llegar
hasta el final sé que matarán a muchos
de nosotros pero al menos será una
muerte rápida prefiero eso a esta lenta
y dolorosa tortura que todos estamos
soportando
llegamos al final de los observadores
por esta semana muchísimas gracias a
rolo café en la ciudad de bogotá por
prestarnos un espacio para realizar la
grabación de este episodio ahora la
pregunta para ustedes fue testigo de un
evento que grabó si la respuesta es sí
no dude en escribirle a nuestro equipo
para contarnos los nuestros contactos
están en pantalla esperamos recibir sus
fotos y videos para que juntos podamos
cubrir la actualidad internacional
en imágenes aficionados siga con más
información en france 24 y france24
puntocom hasta pronto